Wall Street Journal on the doormat top
floor apartment 20 bucks says this guy's
like a hot eligible bachelor I'll take
that action hello hello sir how are you
today I am detective right all the time
and this is my partner detective
terrible detective Santiago takes the
lead with one minute left
suck it Peralta oh no that's right oh no
oh no you don't seem worried why are you
worried
bring in the Jones Irina prostitution
sting through Vice and arrested 30 guys
for soliciting that's not a felony it is
when it's your second offense which is
the case for ten of these gentlemen
fun fact four of them are actually named
John ironic anyhoo ten more for Peralta
accept your fate never five four three
two one Jake wins Amy loses
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
Amy Santiago you have made me the
happiest man on earth I spent one whole
dollar on this ring will you go on the
worst date ever with me you have to say
yes look I don't want to be a jerk I
know you're dating Teddy and it's going
really well
it's just it's good I don't know what's
gonna happen on this assignment and if
something bad goes down I think I'd be
pissed at myself if I didn't say this I
kind of wish something could happen
between us
romantic styles and I know it can't cuz
you're with Teddy and I'm going
undercover and that's how it is but
anyway we're not supposed to have any
contact so I should go America needs me
but you know what we should go no
actually I think you should stay so we
can all talk about the real reason
there's a problem in my relationship
with Amy which is you Jake uh what now
huh
about how you told her that you liked
her before you went undercover do you
like gay me um I did but that was many
moons ago was it because I know for a
fact you also told her when he got back
and every time you would she would get
confused and then our relationship would
get out of sync and if you ask me I
think it's because Amy liked you back
did you maybe yes a little I mean I was
confused and I really need my laptop
right now you know what this is uh
officially too much for me so I'm gonna
go upstairs and rip the heads off some
dolls good night I'm gonna leave too if
you'd please leave my toothbrush and my
home brewing kit at the doorstep I'll
pick them up tomorrow well
I guess that's the last time I invite
Eddie on a trip right drama I'm gonna go
yeah me too
[Music]
can you get the car from the valet table
I'm gonna go in the back and say hi to
the chef
good luck on your wedding guys have fun
on your honeymoon and we will we're
going to Waco Texas huh okay bye bye
Waco Texas I don't know it's just date
Agustin took the laptop case with him
he's gonna make the drop let's go look
there's the buyer or maybe he's just
actually saying hi to the chef
why isn't making the handoff okay excuse
me
oh hey we were just looking for a place
to boink yep
boink that's my preferred term for it as
well I get it we engage kids enjoy good
good good good good
kept our cover and tech nice work quick
professional thinking out there very
quick very professional detective
detective back on the case officially on
a date romantic old 8:00 yes we are no
longer just colleagues dating
you've got a haircut it looks like oh
thanks
you also got a haircut at some point in
your life I'm sure that's not your baby
hair that would be crazy but yeah you
look very nice domme arigato
do you speak Japanese no uh sorry I
think feeling a little awkward
yeah meet you how do we make it not
weird I know
let's just get super drunk yes great
idea pardon me ma'am could you please
bring us four kamikaze shots and four
for me as well ah I like your style see
we can do this we're back on track we're
keeping it light and breezy so we broke
a rule yeah I hope it wasn't a mistake
hope it wasn't a mistake title your sex
tape title of our sex tape they're all
so beautiful and they're all about to be
tested
bouncy styles
[Music]
I love this mattress and it loves having
you in it
god it's Brian oh and I'm obsessed with
giving you a good night's sleep hello
Brian
coming on a little strong there buddy
and I'm digging it how much to take this
bad boy home actually that's one of our
more reasonable models you know holy
Moses that is much too much money oh
well you spent twice that for mr. met to
come to your birthday party yeah and it
was worth it
mr. Medin used my bathroom number two if
that's a memory I will cherish forever
look mattresses are expensive but
they're an investment it's gonna be in
your life for a long time true but it's
also still just a mattress you know it's
a lot of money to spend on a rectangle
that's filled with springs and goose
hair you know it's feathers I didn't and
it would be money well spent because it
would allow me to actually sleep in your
bed but I already have a mattress it
just doesn't seem worth it okay well to
me it sounds like you're saying I'm not
worth it so I'm gonna go sleep in my
grown-up mattress that I bought this
century and you're not invited
you know she's right about mattresses
being an investment back off Brian hey
can I ask you something
if the toilets drain into the ocean does
that mean a tiny shark could swim up and
bite me in the butt no not at all
Wayne look I know you're bummed about
the Pontiac bandit so if it's any
consolation we could spend the rest of
the cruise eating shrimp in bed that is
incredibly sweet but no way we have too
many activities to do yeah you'll never
guess what starts in three minutes so
you can't guess
thank you for doing this and I do
noise smart
[Music]
I love you too
[Music]
also I think this is definitely a dance
class for widows no I don't think so no
now turn to your partner and tell them
how your spouse died yeah we should get
out of here are you sure the cops or
Figgis do have any weapons I have the
pipe we pulled out me I would sooner
surrender than go anywhere near your
gooey body pipe I can't believe Leonardo
lived in this Michelangelo I get he's
kind of a sloppy dude but leo is so
fastidious Jake shut up Sarge we're in a
sewer
I'm goats to talk about the Turtles no
Jake shut up I hear something
[Music]
not an attorney one will be appointed
for you what's up I'm Dan you in what
what I love you I want to move into your
apartment really I'll eat you oh my god
what a beautiful moment and you guys
Amy's ovulating as we speak all all
right into the back you're going to jail
[Music]
Hey I don't get it why did you just have
to let me win I don't know when we were
back there racing through the Miranda
rights I just looked over at you and
thought you're awesome and you're good
at doing things I mean sure I'll miss
towel but your happiness is worth way
more than winning some stupid bet
are you sure about this oh yeah your
apartment is better than mine in every
way imaginable you want to know my first
thought was and we dropped into the
sewer smells like home
he's lying Amy his first thought was
about the Ninja Turtles come on Terry we
were in a sewer he's guns to think about
the turtles
yeah I'm done Stu Terry could use such a
Malfoy yeah Terry
you